[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تلدنا من مدينه
القدس في الاراضي الفلسطينيه بعد يوم طويل
تصدر فيه التوتر المشهد مع مسيره الاعلام
التي تمت هذا العام بمشاركه اعضاء من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
من مجلس الامن جلسه خاصه بشان التطورات في
اوكرانيا في ظل تصاعد حده الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بمشاركه من بنك جزير ووزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه واعضاء في الكنيست ما تعرف
بمسيره الاعلام تخترق البلده القديمه في
القدس وسط توتر واستنفار من شرطه الاحتلال
ونتنياهو يقول انه امر بالمحافظه على
مسارها وبعد الاعتداء على متظاهرين
فلسطينيين في المدينه
يحذر من الاستفزاز ويدعو لضبط النفس
للمره التاسعه في نحو اسبوعين موسكو تشن
موجه هجمات صاروخيه واسعه على كييف
وتستهدف مواقع في الجنوب كياف تقول انها
اسقطت معظم الصواريخ والبنتاجون يقر بتضرر
منظومه ويقول انها عادت للعمل وفي القرن
توقف غير مبرمج في حركه القطارات السلطات
الروسيه تتحدث عن انحراف قطار عن مساره
ومخابرات كييف تقول انه استهداف لخط امداد
روسيا اساسي
الصين على طاوله قمه السبع في هيروشيما
قاده المجموعه يبحثون تطور العلاقات بين
بيجين وموسكو والتوسع العسكري والاقتصادي
لبيجين وفي تحرك صيني مقابل شيجن بينج
يستضيف قمه غير مسبوقه لدول اسيا الوسطى
ويقول ان العلاقات مع بلاده اخذت منعطفا
جديدا
معارك متواصله بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم ونيال تعود الى
دائره التصعيد مع اندلاع معارك عنيفه قرب
مطارها محادثات جده غير المباشره تستمر
وسط تكتم شديد واحتجاج من الخارجيه
السودانيه على استقبال جنوب السودان
مستشاره قائد الدعم السريع
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اصرارا مستوطنين وبمشاركه
من اعضاء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه على
اتمام ما تعرف بمسيره الاعلام في البلده
القديمه وذلك تحت حمايه للشرطه الاحتلال
التي قمعت متظاهرين فلسطينيين واعتقلت
اخرين في المدينه توتر رافقه تحذير من
الامم المتحده ودعوه لطب النفس لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي هل تشكل ما تعرف
بمسيره الاعلام هذا العام بوابه لمزيد من
التصعيد والاستفزاز الفلسطينيين
73% قالوا ان الاستفزاز الاستيطاني
سيتصاعد 17% راوا انه سيتراجع تحت ضغط
الاحتجاجات الفلسطينيه بينما قال 10% انه
سيتراجع بضغط دولي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
اذا شارك عدد من وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه فيما تعرف بمسيره الاعلام
التي دعت لها قوى اسرائيليه متطرفه وسار
الاف المستوطنين والمتطرفين اليهود في
مسيره الاعلام التي تقيمها سنويا الاحزاب
والمنظمات اليهوديه الدينيه والمتطرفه
نقلت مراسله الجزيره ان الامن الاسرائيلي
فرق بالقوه عشرات الفلسطينيين وسط القدس
المحتله بعد رفعهم العلم الفلسطيني بينما
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انه اجرى
اتصالات لضمان عدم تصاعد الاستفزازات
داعيا الى ضبط النفس
مسيره الاعلام مظاهره اسرائيليه متطرفه كل
عام تهدف الى طمس الهويه العربيه
الفلسطينيه في القرص الشريف وجعلها عاصمه
موحده لاسرائيل منذ احتلالها عام 67
سلطات الاحتلال فرضت منذ الصباح طوقا
امنيا حول البلده القديمه وفي محيطها وعلى
ابوابها بل وحتى ازقتها وباحات المسجد
الاقصى
بدايه فرغت الباحات من الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
وذلك تمهيدا لاقتهامها من قبل مستوطنين
ومتطرفين يهود من بينهم اعضاء حاليون
وسابقون في الحكومه والكنيست
الاقتحامات سبقت مسيره ما يعرف برقصه
الاعلام الاف اليهود غالبهم من المستوطنين
يرفعون الاعلام الاسرائيليه في مسيره
تتكرر كل عام تدخل من باب العمود وتجوب في
ازقه البلده القديمه مرورا بالحي الاسلامي
ووصولا الى حائط البراق وزير الامن في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
شارك ايضا في رقصه الاعلام الهدف هو خانق
مدينه القدس بكل قطاعاتها خنق الوجود
الفلسطيني احلال المستوطنين بالقوه مكان
الفلسطينيين تثبيت امر واقع وستاتيكو جديد
في المسجد الاقصى دفع الصحفيين والسكان
الى خارج المدينه اغلاق المحلات التجاريه
بقوه السلاح العربده والاعتداء على اهل
البلد القديمه اذا هدفها بسط السياده ولو
بصوره مفتعله مسيره رقصه الاعلام هذه التي
تتكرر كل عام هي في رمزيتها صراع هويه
تريد اسرائيل من خلالها فرض واقع ضم القدس
بعد احتلالها يقابلها تمسك فلسطيني
بالهويه العربيه للقدس الشرقيه مع رفع
للاعلام الفلسطينيه في مناطق عده من
الاراضي المحتله او المحاصره
اكبر تلك المسيرات كان في قطاع غزه اذ خرج
الالاف في مسيره اعلام فلسطينيه مضاده
ارادوا منها نصره القدس المحتله وتثبيت
وجود الفلسطينيين على ارضهم
واظهار تمسكهم بحقوقهم المشاركه في فعاليه
تحت عنوان فعاليه العالم الفلسطيني ردا
على فعاليه العالم والصهيوني في القسم
نؤكد على وحده الشعب الفلسطيني في القدس
وغزه والضفه والشتات وان المعركه معركه
السياده في القدس وعلى القدس مع هذا
المحتل لم تنتهي ولم يسلم شعب فلسطيني
ابدا بسياده العدو عليها تعاني القدس كل
عام منذ الذكرى الاولى لاحتلالها قبل سته
وخمسين عاما مسيرات ما يسمى رقصه الاعلام
التي كانت محدوده في البدايه لكنها تحولت
خلال الاعوام القليله الماضيه الى مسيره
حاشده يشارك فيها الالاف من انصار الاحزاب
اليمينيه واليمنيه المتطرفه في اسرائيل
التي تدفع بالمغالاه في فرض سياسه التهويد
احمد هزيم الجزيره القدس المحتله
من رام الله ينضم الينا الدكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت مرحبا بك دكتور غسان ما الذي ميز
ما يعرف في مسيره الاعلام هذا العام عن
الاعوام السابقه كما تابعتها
لا تختلف كثيرا مسيره الاعلام في هذا في
هذا العام عن الاعوام السابقه في الاعوام
الاخيره بما فيه هذا العام
يلاحظ ازدياد عدد
الاسرائيليين المشاركين في هذه المسيره
ومشاركه اعداد اكثر من كبار السياسيين
اليمينيين المشاركين في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولكن هذا الحدث السنوي ليس
جديد فهو يتكرر منذ عشرات السنين وهو واحد
من جمله اجراءات وسياسات وانشطه اسرائيليه
تهدف الى احكام السيطره على القدس الشرقيه
المحتله ولكن هذه التظاهره تحمل في طياتها
ايضا تعويضا او محاوله تظاهريه للتعويض عن
حقيقه ان اسرائيل وبالرغم من مرور خمسين
عاما لم تنجح حقيقه في تهويد القدس ولم
تنجح في جعلها عاصمه موحده لدوله اسرائيل
برغم من الاستثمارات الماليه والعسكريه
والقانونيه الهائله التي تمارسها اسرائيل
عبر السنوات الخمسين الماضيه الا انه
القدس ما زالت فيها اكثريه عربيه ومازال
فيها طابع عربي وما زال ابناء القدس ابناء
الشعب الفلسطيني في القدس متمسكونا في
ارضهم
وفي بيوتهم مما يفشل
الجهد الاستراتيجي الاسرائيلي الهادف الى
طمس هذه المدينه ما هو غير مثبت
هذا صحيح ولكن دكتور غسان كثر توقفوا
اليوم عند مشاركه وزراء في الحكومه في هذه
المسيره هل من دلالات معينه لذلك
نعم يعني واضح ان الحكومه الحاليه بالرغم
من انها لا تختلف بالجوهر عن الحكومات
السابقه فكل الحكومات المتعاقبه عملت بكل
ما لديها من قوه على تهويد القدس
وسواء كانت حكومات يمنيه ام يساريه اضافه
الى توسيع الاستيطان في القدس والاراضي
المحتله عموما ولكن خصوصا في القدس ولكن
هذه الحكومه
تمارس نفس السياسه بطريقه فجه وبطريقه
مفضوحه وبطريقه في الحقيقه متهوره ومن
شانها من وجهه نظري على الاقل ان تلحق
الاذى بصوره اسرائيل ومكانتها الدوليه
وتصعب عليها علاقاتها الخارجيه وهذا ما
بدا يظهر الحقيقه على مستوى العلاقات
الدوليه لاسرائيل هناك تزايد في
الانتقادات الاسرائيليه لان هذه الحكومه
ازالت القناع عن حقيقه الوجه
الحقيقي
لاسرائيل وحكوماتها المتعاقبه التي كانت
تحاول ان تمارس الاستيطان وتنتهك حقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن بشكل متستر
ودبلوماسي ويحاول ان يعطي صوره
مغايره لخدمه غايات العلاقات الخارجيه
التي تحتاجها اسرائيل دائما طيب ماذا بعد
هذه المسيره هل سيكون هناك تبعات لما حدث
اليوم
لا اعتقد بانه سيكون هناك تبعات مباشره
هي هي من جمله المحاولات الاسرائيليه
المتراكمه والمتواليه الهادفه الى تحقيق
اهداف اسرائيل في القدس وهي تهويل القدس
وجعلها اسرائيليه هذه المحاولات التي لم
تنجح وفي اعتقادي انها لن تنجح لانه تمسك
ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني في مدينتهم وبيوتهم
ومقدساتهم المسيحيه والاسلاميه هو تمسك
اسطوري بالمقارنه بالجهد الهائل لاسرائيل
لمحاوله طربهم من بيوتهم ومحاوله جعل
حياتهم صعبه من اجل تهويد المدينه شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور غسان الخطيب استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت ضيفه من
رام الله
بعد عام من احتلال القدس كامله بشقيها
الشرقي والغربي قررت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تثبيت التاريخ يوما لتوحيد القدس في العام
نفسه جمع الحاخام المتطرف
اتبعه ورفعوا العلم الاسرائيلي في محيط
باب العمود بعد السته اعوام نظمت الميدو
كوك الحاخام المتطرف في هدى حزاني مسيره
لرفع العلم الاسرائيلي يعتبر حازاني احد
قاده الصهيونيه الدينيه انتجت الصهيونيه
الدينيه في اخر تجلياتها لتمر اصبح بنجبير
وزيرا في حكومه توصف بالاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل الى جانب وزراء اخرين
ابرزهم سكوتريتش الذي دعا سابقا الى محو
قريه حوار الفلسطينيه هنا ينفس موتريتش
وجود شعب فلسطيني اصلا تصريحات اثارت
سابقا غضبا واسعا وكشفت وجها اخر للحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده يشارك هذان الوزيران
الى جانب مسؤولين ووزراء اخرين في مسيره
الاعلام هذا العام
تجبر سلطات الاحتلال الفلسطينيين من اصحاب
المحال في البلده القديمه بالقدس على
اغلاقها يوم المسيره تنطلق المسيره من
الشق الغربي للمدينه الى باب العامود
تحديدا ويدخل بعض المستوطنين من باب
الخليل نقطه النهايه هي الحائط الغربي
للمسجد الاقصى حائط البراق هنا يتجمع
المستوطنون ويرقصون باعلامهم قبل عامين
منعت الحكومه الاسرائيليه مرور المسيره
عبر باب العمود وحولت المسار الى باب
الخليل لتفادي مرورها بالحي الاسلامي مع
تجمع المستوطنين في باب العمود حينها
اطلقت المقاومه الفلسطينيه دفعه من
الصواريخ باتجاه القدس فتفرقت المسيره
واندلعت معركه سيف القدس وفق التقديرات
وقد كلفت المسيره عام 2018 قرابه
الثلاثمائه الف دولار امريكي
تلك مسيره بدات متواضعه عام 74 يسخر منها
التيار العلماني في اسرائيل ووصلت اليوم
لتصبح علامه استفزاز استيطاني تشارك فيها
وتدعمها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تعرض قناه الجزيره مساء غد الجمعه تحقيقا
خاصا من برنامج ما خفي اعظم بالتزامن مع
ذكرى السنويه الاولى لاغتيال الزميله
شيرين ابو عقله على يد جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واجرى مقدم البرنامج الزميل
تامر المسحال لقاءات حصريه لا سيما مع
الخبير الامريكي الذي تولى عمليه تحليل
المقاطع المصوره والصوتيه لجريمه الاغتيال
والذي حسم الجدل في مصدر الرصاصه التي
قتلت الزميله شيرين اثناء تغطيتها
الميدانيه في جنين التحقيق الذي يحمل
عنوان قتل الادله يكشف بالوثائق والشهادات
السياسه الاسرائيليه الممنهجه في التهرب
من العقاب في قضايا قتل الصحفيين في
فلسطين كما يتضمن التحقيق مقابلات مع
محققين دوليين حققوا في قضايا اغتيال
الصحفيين على يد جيش الاحتلال ما خفي اعظم
قتل الادله ياتيكم مساء غد الجمعه عند
10:05 بتوقيت
مكه المكرمه على شاشه الجزيره ومنصاتها
المختلفه
[موسيقى]
للمره التاسعه جنه القوات الروسيه هجمات
صاروخيه على كييف ومدن اوكرانيه اخرى وضمن
بنك الاهداف الاساسيه كانت منظومات دفاعيه
غربيه هذا الهجوم قالت اوكرانيا انها تصدت
له وقودت نجاحه باسقاط معظم الصواريخ وعلى
الرغم من النفي الاوكراني الا ان
الفينتاجون اقرر اقر بتضرر منظومه جراء
الضربات لكنه اشار الى اصلاحها وعودتها
الى العمل
بشكل لافتين تعود ثياب العاصمه الاوكرانيه
لتتصدر المشهد مع تعرضها لهجمه صاروخيه
تصفها السلطات الاوكرانيه بانها غير
مسبوقه في كثافتها وقوتها وتنوعها بصورخ
روسيه قالت السلطات انها باليستيه ومشنحه
وفرط صوتيه الهجوم الذي يعتبر التاسعه على
التوالي منذ بدايه شهر مايو جاري تم ب 30
صاروخا من نوع كروز وفق قائد القوات
الاوكرانيه اطلقت من منصات بحريه وجويه
وارضيه بينها صاروخ اسكندر في هجوم متزامن
من اتجاهات مختلفه تتحدث القوات
الاوكرانيه عن صد تسعه وعشرين منها
بالاضافه الى طائرتين مسيرتين من طرز شاهد
وطائره استطلاع تؤكد وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قوتها استهدفت في اكثر من هجوم
مستودعات للذخيره الاجنبيه ودمرت مدافع
هاودزر واعترضت منظومه الصواريخ هايبرس
استخدمت منظومه الصواريخ الجويه المضاده
للطائرات
تعزو المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليه الجنوب
الاوكراني الهجوم الروسيه الواسعه الى
مقاله انه محاوله لاستنفاذ الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه مع تزويد الدول الغربيه
كييف بانظمه دفاع جوي من هذه المنظومات
نظام اس 300 ويصل مداه الى 250 كيلومترا
وهو قادر على التصدي الصواريخ الباليسيه
التي لا تتجاوز سرعتها
4500 متر في الثانيه اضافه الى منظومه
الامريكيه بمدى يصل الى 50 كيلومترا وهو
نظام متوسط المدى يمكنه التعامل مع
مقاتلات ومروحيات وصواريخ كروز ومسيرات
فمنظومه ايريستي الالمانيه بمدى يصل لنحو
40 كيلومترا وهي من افضل انظمه الدفاع
متوسطه المدى وتستطيع صد الطائرات
المقاتله والمروحيات والصواريخ كروز
والمسيرات
تتبع هذه التطورات اعلان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قبل ايام استخدامها الصواريخ من
طراز كنجال في كييف تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت لتدمير محطه رادار متعدده الوظائف
وخمس قذفات لمنظومه باتريوت الامريكيه
المضاده للطائرات لكن مسؤولين امريكيين
قللوا من الاضرار التي لحقت بالمنظومه
وقالوا انها لا تزال قيد التشغيل ولم
يتضرر مكون الرادار مؤكدين ان اصلاحه لا
يتطلب سحبه من ساحه المعركه ومنظومه
باتريوت الامريكيه يصل مداها الى 160
كيلومترا وتعتبر نظاما دفاعيا بعيدا مدى
قادرا على حمايه المنشاه العسكريه
والقواعد من الهجمات الجويه ويشمل ردارا
ومحطه تحكم ومولد طاقه ومنصات اطلاق
ومركبه دعم
[موسيقى]
بتزامل مع ذلك اعلنت سلطات شبه جزيره
القرم المواليه لروسيا استكمال اعمال
الصيانه في سكه الحديد المتضرره بين
سنفروبل وسيفا ستوبل على ان تستانف حركه
النقل بشكل كامل يوم غد ياتي ذلك عقب
تعليق عمل القطارات اثر خروج قطار شحن عن
مساره وكان جهاز امن الدوله الروسيه اكد
فتحه تحقيق في اسباب الحادث على يتم
الاعلان عن نتائجه بعد اتمام عمليات
التحقيق وفي السياق نفسها اكدت هيئه السكك
الحديديه في القرم ان خروج قطار الشحن عن
مساره بسبب تدخل اشخاص من الخارج في عمل
السكه الحديديه
من جانب قال اندريه المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه تعقيبا على الحادث
الذي وقع صباح اليوم على مسار للسكه
الحديديه في شبه جزيره القرم ان المسار
المستهدف كان ينقل من خلاله الذخيره
والعتاد والجنود الروس لمواصله ما وصفه
بالعدوان على بلاده
المسار المذكور لم يكن ينقل الحبوب فقط
وانما الاسلحه والذخيره والعربات المدرعه
ومجموعات القتال لمواصله العدوان الروسي
على اوكرانيا لقد ساعد ذلك الخط على قتل
المدنيين والمدافعين الاوكرانيين ومن
الطبيعي تماما ان مثل هذه المسارات لن
تستطيع التحمل وستتعرض للتعب والخروج عن
الخدمه لفتره معينه البنيه التحتيه في شبه
جزيره القرم ستعمل بشكل مسؤول وامن فقط
عندما يتم تحريرها من قبل اوكرانيا طالما
ظل الارهابيون الروس هناك فلن تعيش السلام
المنشود
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
اليكساندر ارتامونوف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ومعنى من كييف اوليكسيه
عفوا مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق
مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك
ماذا تحقق روسيا من وراء هذا التكثيف
للضربات الصاروخيه على كييف ومدن اخرى
تقوم بتدمير انظمه الدفاع الجويه التي
تدافع عن المدن الاوكرانيه وتدمر مستودعات
الذخيره وتقوم بتعطيل البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه حتى تزعزع الخطط الحربيه ان
روسيا تقوم بتحقيق هذه الخطه خطه تدمير
البنيه التحتيه للمدن
الاوكرانيه وهذا يحدث بعد انتباه
الاستراتيجيين الروس
لضروره
الحفاظ على مواقعهم لان المواقع الروسيه
تدمر تماما بينما المدن الاوكرانيه تبقى
في حالتها السليمه ولن نقوم برحمه البنيه
التحتيه الروسيه الاوكرانيه عفوا بعد
اليوم لكن الطرف الاوكراني يقول انه يتمكن
من تدمير معظم هذه الصواريخ قبل ان تبلغ
اهدافها
ما الجدوى اذا
الخط تقطع ممكن ان تعيد السؤال الاوكراني
سيد الكسندر يقول انه يتمكن يتمكن من
تدمير معظم هذه الصواريخ قبل ان تبلغ
اهدافها ما الجد واذا
تعلمون انني افهم جيدا ما قد يعلنه الطرف
الاوكراني انهم يقومون بمعاقبه
مشهورين الانترنت الذين يقومون بتصوير
الاهداف التي تصيبها الصواريخ
الروسيه اذا كنا سوف نصدق الطرف الاوكراني
والمكتب الرئاسي
حتى اليوم دمرت
منظومتين ثقيلتين من طراز
وحسب ما اعلمه ان هناك ايضا حديث عن تدمير
منظومات المانيه وفي نفس الوقت هناك مقاطع
فيديو
تظهر الانفجارات الضخمه في كييف وهذا
موجود في كل مكان سيد اوليكس ملك ما رايك
هذه الصواريخ وهذه الاستراتيجيه الجديده
على ما يبدو من جانب روسيا هل تحقق
الاهداف التي يتحدث عنها السيد الكسندر
اذا كان الحديث عما تحدث عنه الضيف
الروسي ان هذا الموقف الرسمي في روسيا
فهذا اعتراف ان روسيا تقوم
بابادات جماعيه ضد المجتمع المدني وهذا
ارهاب ان تدمير البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
هذا ارهاب دولي
وهذا شيء غير جديد على روسيا اما بالنسبه
للنجاحات او الفشل من وجهه نظره نظري انا
كمواطن في كيف استطيع ان اؤكد ان اخر
هجمتين لم تصب اي هدف لا بمنشاه مدنيه ولا
غيرها كل ما تضررنا منه هي الشظايا التي
حطمت بعد النوافذ
وهذا دليل على انه لم يكن هناك اي اصابات
ضد منظومات او غيرها
يتطابق مع روايه المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
ولكن البانتاجون خرج ليعترف بان الصواريخ
الروسيه الحقت الضرر بمنظومه بيتريت
نعم هناك تاكيد من قلب بنتاجون ان هناك
تضرر باحدى البطاريات التي تطلق الصواريخ
فهذا ليس ضرر بالمنظومه التي تحتوي على
عشرات منصات الاطلاق ان المنصه الواحده هي
عنصر صغير جدا ولكن حتى هذا سمح لنا في
اليوم التالي ان ندمر ثمانيه عشر صاروخ من
اصل 20 هاجمت كيف سيد الكسندر ارتامو نوف
ما تحدثت عنه عن
نيه روسيا تدمير البنى التحتيه في هذه
المدن من جراء اطلاق هذه الصواريخ يقول لك
ضيفنا من كاف هو اعتراف بارهاب الدوله كيف
ترد
كلمات
السيد
متضاربه وهذا واضح انا اتحدث عن تدمير
البنيه التحتيه في المدن وليس المدن ذاتها
هو قال انه في كيف
وقال ان كيف سليمه لم ندمر المدينه لم
ندمر
الطرق والسكك الحديد الكسندر هو قال تدمير
البنيه التحتيه يعتبر
ارهابا ارهاب دوله
لذلك ارد عليك واقول انا اقوم بالرد ان
البنيه التحتيه لا تعني تدمير الاحياء نحن
نتحدث عن شكك الحديد ونتحدث عن منشات
الكهرباء وطرق الامدادات هذه هي البنيه
التحتيه وليس المدن ان الاوكرانيون هم من
يدمروا المدن وممكن ان تشاهدوا هذا في
الدمباص وفي دنيسك سوف ترون المدارس
والرياضه الاطفال المدمره والمستشفيات
ايضا هذا شيء واضح جدا رد علي سيد
انا استطيع ان اؤكد اننا ان الدباس المدن
التي تسميها روسيا محرره مريومه
هذه المدن التي مسحت من وجه الارض التي
دمرت بالطائرات الروسيه واوكرانيا لم تكن
تستطيع ان تستخدم المقاتلات وفي نفس الوقت
روسيا استخدمت حوالي
80 الف قذيفه في اليوم وهذه القذائف كانت
تسقط ليس على المواقع العسكريه الاوكرانيه
بل على المدن ايضا
اماكييف فانا لا اعتقد ان العسكريين
الاوكرانيين سيستخدمون كيف حتى يخزنوا
الاسلحه والذخائر او ان يقوموا بتمرير هذه
المعدات عن طريق كيف لذلك توجيه الضربات
على كيف هي ضربات ضد المدنيين والبنيه
التحتيه هناك هي ما تؤمن الحياه في
المدينه للامنين والمدنيين اشكركما
اوليكسي منك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
السابق من كيف وسيد الكسندر ارتامونوف
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
في حديث اخر عن روسيا ولكن من زاويه
علاقاتها مع الصين يناقش قاده مجموعه
السبع في مدينه هيروشيما اليابانيه سبل
ابقاء العقوبات على موسكو بتحذير بيجين من
الالتفاف على العقوبات وبالتزامن مع قمه
مجموعه السبع التي تناقش ايضا توسع بيجين
العسكري والاقتصادي يستضيف الرئيس الصيني
زعماء دول اسيا الوسطى في قمه هي الاولى
من نوعها منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي
في المدينه التي دمرتها قنبله نوويه
امريكيه قبل نحو ثمانيه عقود تجتمع في
هيروشيما اليابانيه الدول السبع الكبار
وعلى راس اولوياتها كبح جماح تطلعات الخصم
الصيني بتوسيع نفوذه العسكري في بحر جنوب
الصين والحاء اول دون ان تكون له اليد
العليا في حركه الاقتصاد العالمي اضافه
الى نقاش العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
وامكانيه توجيه رسائل تحذيريه لبيجين بعدم
الالتفاف على العقوبات الاقتصاديه
المفروضه على موسكو عبر بيعها منتجات
مزدوجه لاستخدام على ان اللافته في القمه
التي تجمع اكبر الاقتصاديات المتقدمه في
العالم واغنى الدول المتبنيه للديمقراطيه
الليبراليه تاكيد بعض المشاركين فيها انها
لن تسعى الى فك الارتباط الاقتصادي مع
الصين بل الى صياغه معادله متوازنه لا
تصبح معها المخاطر الناجمه عن الاعتما على
دوله او عدد قليل من الدول كبيره بشكل
مفرط بحسب تعبير المستشار الالماني
غير بعيد عنه اليابانيه تنعقد قمه موازيه
في مدينه شي ان الصينيه لا يبدو توقيتها
مجرد مصادفه بحته فبيجين تريد تاكيد بان
لديها خياراتها ايضا من خلال تعزيز حضورها
الاقتصادي في اسيا الوسطى وزياده
استثماراتها هناك في مجال الطاقه فالقمه
التي يشارك فيها رؤساء كازاخستان
وقرغيزستان وترك مونستان واوزبكستان تعد
الاولى من نوعها منذ تاسيس العلاقات
الرسميه قبل اكثر من ثلاثه عقود بين بيجين
وهذه الدول بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفياتي
وستسعى الصين من خلالها الى تعزيز التعاون
الاقتصادي وزياده حجم التبادل التجاري مع
تلك الدول الذي وصل العام الماضي الى نحو
70 ملي ار دولار ولا سيما ان القمه ستشهد
التوقيع على عدد من الاتفاقات التي من
شانها اعطاء دفعه لما يعرف بطريق الحرير
الجديد المشروع الصيني العملاق الذي يبدا
من مدينه شيان ويتضمن انشاء الطرقات وسكك
حديديه ومناطق صناعيه في دول اسيا الوسطى
لتسريع وصول منتجاتها الى الاسواق
العالميه
بعد قليل في فقرتي في المتابعه سيكون لنا
نقاش اوسع عن القمم والقمم المضاده وفيها
سنركز اكثر على مساعي الصين في بناء
علاقات علاقات توسع مجالات نفوذها عالميا
[موسيقى]
الى السودان وتزامنا مع استمرار محادثات
جد غير مباشره بين ممثلي الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع اندلعت اشتباكات بين قوات
الجانبين بالاسلحه الثقيله في الخرطوم كما
شهدت مدينه الفاشر مركز اقليم دارفور
وعاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور تبادلا كثيفا
لاطلاق النار في هذه الاثناء ذكرت مصادر
طبيه في السودان ان عدد الضحايا منذ بدء
المواجهات تجاوز 830 قتيلا وما يزيد على
ثلاثه الاف مصاب
كلمه السر السيطره لاجلها تخابر المعارك
لاكثر من شهر في السودان ما زال اشرس
القتال يتركز حول مثلث العاصمه الخرطوم
بحري واندرمان وفي ثلاثه تظل اعين الجيش
والدعم السريع على مواقع استراتيجيه
يرصد مراسلنا بجنوب الخرطوم وقوع اشتباكات
بين قوات الجانبين في الاسلحه الثقيله على
الطريق المؤدي لولايه النيل الابيض
في تطورات القتال الاخرى هزا انفجار وسط
العاصمه السودانيه دون ان تتسنى معرفه
ملابساته
ما لا يعرفه احد حتى الان هو مال هذه
المواجهه السودانيه السودانيه التي امتدت
بشكل مقلق غربان
تقول مصادر الجزيره الى مدينه الفاشر مركز
اقليمي دارفور وعاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور
شهد التبادلا كثيفا لاطلاق النار بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
وذكرت المصادر ان القوتين تطلقان النار من
مواقع تمركزهما في المدينه ولم تنتشر في
اي مواقع جديده
الى متى القتال يسال عبوه السودانيين منذ
بدءها منتصف الشهر الماضي اوقعت
الاشتباكات المستمره في بلدهم حسب لجنه
اطباء السودان ما لا يقل عن
833 قتيله اما المصابون فهم اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف وثمانمائه
لا تحسب التكلفه البشريه لاي حرب بعدد من
تزهقه من ارواح او تلحقه من اصابات فقط
فمن سلموا من نيران المعارك تطبق عليهم
ماساه الانسانيه تتعاظم
تنبه مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين بالامم المتحده
الا ان القتال الدائره في السودان ادى
لنزوح اكثر من مليون شخص وتقول المفوضيه
انها بحاجه لاربع مئه مليون دولار لحمايه
هؤلاء النازحين ومساعده المجتمعات التي
تستضيفهم
يجتمع من فرو ومن خلفهم ورائهم على امنيه
واحده هدنه توقف صوت الرصاص
في ذلك الاتجاه تعمل محادثات جدا غير
المباشره بين ممثلين عن الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع هذا مسعا دونه معوقات لكنه
يحاول البناء على اعلان المبادئ الخاص
بحمايه المدنيين وتلبيه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه العاجله
قالت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه انها ارسلت
مذكره احتجاج شديده اللهجه الى حكومه جنوب
السودان بسبب استقبالها ما وصفته بمستشار
قائد ميليشيا الدعم السريع المتمرده وعقد
مؤتمر صحفي بحضور مسؤولين كبار بحكومه
جنوب السودان اضافت الخارجيه السودانيه في
بيان لها انها عبرت خلال المذكره عن
احتجاجها واستغرابها من تصرف حكومه جنوب
السودان
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو اسامه عيدروس
محلل الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه
مرحبا بك سيد اسامه كيف يمكن ما وصف وصف
ما ال اليه القتال الان وكاننا دخلنا
مرحله من المراوحه لا يستطيع فيها اي من
الطرفين السيطره وفي الحقيقه هذه هذا ما
ظهر في الاعلام منذ بدايه الحرب وظهر حتى
في تقارير الدول التي تحدث عن هذه الحرب
ان هذه الحرب لا يمكن لاي احد من الطرفين
ان يكسبها عن طريق الاله العسكريه وليس
فيها منتصر وعلى هذا الاساس كل المبادرات
من الخارج تحدثت على هذا الاساس
النقاش في مجلس الامن الدولي كان على هذا
الاساس النقاش في
المفاوضات التي بدات في جده دارت على هذا
الاساس انه هذه الحرب لا يمكن الانتصار
فيها على الارض
ما جرى منذ بدايه الحرب حتى الان
يعني اوصل قوات الدعم السريع الى مرحله
يعني هي في حيره من امرها
المفاوضات عندما بدات في جده لم يناقشوا
وقف اطلاق النار
وتكلموا عن مبادئ عامه
للاجراءات التي تخفف على المدنيين كما هي
في القانون الدولي وتفتح مسارات للترتيبات
لفتح مسارات للاغاثه والاغانه وغيرها الان
تغير الامر يعني مستشار الدعم السريع في
جنوب السودان ويقال انه الان سيذهب الى
يوغندا مع احتجاج وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه يبحث فعلا عن وقف لاطلاق النار
من هدف سياسي سيطر على البلاد لماذا يجري
البحث عنه في جنوب السودان واوغندا وهناك
محادثات جاريه في جده المحادثات في جده
سقفها تحدد منذ البدايه انها لفتح
المسارات الانسانيه
والتواصل لوقف اطلاق النار يسمح بالتخفيف
على المدنيين والخروج من المستشفيات
والمرافق وغيرها لكن هذا بحث عن وقف اطلاق
نار لانه القوات الان داخل الخرطوم ليس
لها هدف عسكري يعني اصبحت معركه بلا هدف
عسكري زاد النهب زاد كسر البنوك زادت
حالات الاغتصاب زادت تعدي على السكان على
المواطنين دون ان يكون هنالك يعني مسار
عملياتي واضح لقوات الدعم السريع لا احد
الان يعرف ما الذي ستفعله هذه القوات في
الخطوه القادمه كل هجوم قامت به على
معسكرات الجيش المعسكرات القويه في
البدايه القياده
القاعده العسكريه غيرها من الامور فشلت ثم
حاولت الاجهزه الفنيه سلاح الاشاره سلاح
الاسئله وصلت الى الهجوم على فرع الرياض
العسكريه وصلت الى الهجوم على الاحتياط
المركزي صباح اليوم وفشلت في تحقيق نصر
عسكري على الارض الان هي هائمه ودائره
يعني لا نعرف ما هو الهدف العسكري القادم
الذي يمكن ان يحقق لها اي نص على الارض
فشلت في ذلك
اصبحت في ورطه
تحولت قواتها الى قوات تحاول النهب حتى
يعني مقرات الدعم السريع ومنازل
الدجل تعرضت للنهب من نفس هذه القوات في
غفله من الرغيب يعني نهب شامل من هذه
القوات وليس هنالك
اي وجهه عسكريه يمكن ان تحقق بها النص على
الارض من جديد شكرا شكرا لك اسامه عيدروس
محلل الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه السودانيه
ضيفنا هنا في استوديو الحصاد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
تشهد مخيمات اللاجئين الروهينيا في
بنغلاديش قرب الحدود مع اقليم اراكان
نزوحا عبر رحلات بحريه باتجاه اندونيسيا
بايقاع مرتفع في ملف خاص بقضيه الروهينيا
يرصد مراسلنا صهيب جاسم في هذا التقرير
قصص بعض اللاجئين الذين وصلوا الى اقليم
اتشيل اندونيسي قادمين من بنغلاديش
منذ ثلاثه عشر عاما بدا الروهنجيا الهجره
بحرا نحو سواحل اندونيسيا الغربيه تتفاوت
اعدادهم من سنه لاخرى فبعد انحسار لافت
خلال عامي الجائحه شهدت الاسابيع الاخيره
تزايدا في اعداد الفارينه من مخيمات
النازحين في بنغلاديش الى اندونيسيا هنا
سيطول مقامهم وقد يمتد لسنوات
اول ما يطلبه الناجون من رحله بحريه ملئها
المخاطره هو الاتصال بذويهم بطمئنتهم على
احوالهم
لا نسمع صوتك كيف حالكم اخبرنا ماذا حصل
معكم
عاصفه
ومطر نحن في السفينه وسط البحر وقد مات
كثيرون منا وكنا من الناجين ووصلنا والحمد
لله
اللافت ان الغالبيه منهم شباب واطفال
ونسوه خلافا لمن هاجر في سنوات سابقه حيث
كان عدد كبار السن اكثر عبد الشكور احد
هؤلاء يحلم بالهجره اسوه باخوه له سبقوه
قبل سنوات الى ماليزيا والولايات المتحده
منازلنا فهربنا الى بنجلاديش حيث مخيمات
اللاجئين لكن لا تعليم ولا تحسن في حياتنا
اقتصاديا ولذلك فررنا الى اندونيسيا الحلو
هنا احسن واهلها يرحبون بنا
خمسه اسابيع قضاها اللاجئون الرهنجيا على
متن هذه السفينه في رحله امتدت من خليج
البنغالي شمالا وعبر المحيط الهندي وصولا
الى هذه السواحل في اقليم اكشن اندونيسي
ضمن مسار بحري سلكه الاف من الهلال
السنوات الماضيه ظاهره تطرح تساؤلات جذريه
عن هذه الرحله المحفوفه بالمخاطر
[موسيقى]
فالرحله البحريه من سواحل الحدود بين
بنغلاديش ومين مار تمر ببحر اندامان غربيه
تايلاند وتتجاوز غربيه ماليزيا الى مضيق
ملقه يدفع فيها اللاجئون لتجار الموت
مبالغ قد تتضاعف خلال الرحله
في مخيمات اللاجئين في كوكس بازار يفر
اللاجئون من الاضطهاد او الصراعات
التاركين اهليهم وراءهم بحثا عن مكان اكثر
امنا ويواجهون صعوبات ومخاطر خلال الرحله
فس الرحله يغرونهم بالرحيل لكنهم يواجهون
خطر الموت جوعا يعز ناشطون ارتفاع اعداد
اللاجئين الى حاله الياس التي عاصفت باكثر
من مليون نازح في مخيمات كوكس بازار في
بنغلاديش بعد ان فقدوا الامل في تحسن
احوالهم المعيشيه بدا اكبر مخيم للاجئين
في العالم يتشكل منذ موجه نزوح في
التسعينيات ثم تضاعف العدد اثر موجه عنف
ونزوح عام 2017
[تصفيق]
وتجمع عشرات الالاف منهم للمطالبه بتسويه
قضيتهم بضمانات دوليه تمهيدا لعودتهم الى
قراهم بعد ان ايقنوا ان الظفره بفرصه
للعيش بكرامه غايه لا تدركها الا قله منهم
صاحب جاسم الجزيره اقليم اتشي الاندونيسي
بالعوده الى موضوع القمه التي تعقد في
الصين وتستضيف قاده دول اسيا الوسطى هنا
في مدينه شيان افتتح الرئيس الصيني شيجن
بينج القمه فيما ينظر اليه على انه سعي
لبسط نفوذ اقليمي لكن لماذا مدينه شيان
الجواب لانها تقع في اقصى شرق طريق الحرير
الذي سيربط الصين واوروبا عبر اسيا الوسطى
اي عبر دول المشاركه في هذه القمه وهي
كازاخستان
وقرغيزيستان وطاجيكستان واوزبكستان
وتركمان لكن هذه الدول كما نرى كانت من
جمهوريات الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا ثم باتت
مجال نفوذ روسي فما الذي تفعله الصين هناك
البعض يخمن بان انشغال موسكو في الحرب على
اوكرانيا خلق فراغا يحاول اخرون ملاه
بينما يقول الارقام بشكل قطعي ان الصين
تنمي استثمارات هناك بشكل ضخم في مجالات
الغاز الطبيعي والمنى التحتيه التي ستخدم
لاحقا مبادره الحزام والطريق الصينيه
البالغه قيمتها تريليون دولار والتي تعد
ابرز مشروع جيوسياسي في عهد
لنتحدث قليلا عن هذه الارقام فمثلا تؤكد
باجين ان حجم التجاراتها مع الدول الخمس
بلغ 70 مليار دولار في عام 2022 وسجل نموا
بنسبه
22% خلال الفصل الاول من 2023
فيما تشهد القمه جهودا لاقامه شبكات نقل
وانابيب طاقه تشمل مشروع اقامه سكك حديد
تربط بين الصين وقرغيزيستان واوزباكستان
تبلغ تكلفتها 6 مليارات دولار وهذه في بعض
الارقام فقط للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من روما الدكتور لورنسو تيربيني
الباحث المختص في شؤون الشؤون الاسيويه في
مركز الدراسات الجيو السياسيه وجامعه
ومعنا كذلك من موسكو
معنا من موسكو اذا الدكتور محمود الحمزه
الاكاديمي والباحث في شؤون روسيا واسيا
الوسطى مرحبا بكم سنبدا معك من روما دكتور
لورينزو ترميني ما هي الاهداف التي تسعى
اليها الصين من وراء عقد هذه القمه
المشتركه بين الصين ودول اسيا الوسطى
شكرا على استضافه يسعدني ان اكون معكم
الهدف ينقسم الى قسمين من جانب الصين
تحاول
ان تسعى للتحقيق امنها في مناطقها الغربيه
وحدودها الغربيه وعلى ان نتذكر ان حدود
الصين
الغربيه هي بمثابه خاسره ضعيفه في البنيه
الامنيه للصين لهذا السبب تحاولوا ان تجعل
من تدعيم امنها على هذه الجبهه اولويه لها
البعد الاخر هو بعد اقتصادي نعلم ان روسيا
تعاني
من اثار العقوبات التي تفرض عليها وحتى
رغم الكميات الكبيره من الغاز والنفط التي
يمكن ان تصدرها روسيا الى الصين الصين
تريح تريد البحث عن مصادر اخرى من بلدان
اسيا الوسطى دكتور محمود الحمزه كيف يمكن
لروسيا ان تنظر الى هذا التقارب بين الصين
واسيا الوسطى خصوصا ان هذه البلدان
المشاركه في القمه
تعدها روسيا منطقه نفوذ لها
نعم الحقيقه ان روسيا يعني من الارز
السوفيتي تعتبر اسيا الوسطى هي يعني حاضنه
وحديقه خلفيه لها لكن اللي شاهدناه في
السنوات الماضيه هو حدوث خلافات وفوارق
كبيره بين روسيا والعديد من هذه الدول
وخاصه على ضوء السياسه الخارجيه الروسيه
من جورجيا الى اوكرانيا الى مالطابيا الى
مناطق اخرى
الجمهوريات الاسلاميه في اسيا الوسطى
متخوفه من هذه بعض الممارسات الروسيه الى
جانب ان الروس النخبه الروسيه الحاكمه
تتعامل مع الجمهوريات اسيا الوسطى بطريقه
يعني تحاول ان تهيمن عليها لا ان تتعامل
معها بشكل متكافئ وهذا عبر عنه رئيس
طاجكستان في العام الماضي في قمه في في
اسيا الوسطى عقدت في اسنا او في السمرقن
قال الرئيس للرئيس بوتين على الهواء
مباشره قال له نحن نحترمكم ونقدر مصالحكم
ونطلب منكم ان تحترمونا يعني كلام كان هذا
كثير والرئيس الكازاخي في منتدى الاقتصادي
في ايضا
الاخير العام الماضي يعني امن سنتين عفوا
قال بمنتهى الصراحه نحن لم نعترف باب
خازيه وباستقلال يعني
دكتور محمود كيف يمكن ان تتعامل روسيا مع
هذا هذه المحاوله للتقارب بين الصين وهذه
الدول
طبعا يعني بالجانب الرسمي والعلني هم
يبدون التعامل الايجابي يعني ان الصين بلد
صديق ودول اسيا الوسطى كلها صديقه
وبالتالي شيء لا يضر لكن في تحليل العميق
يعني نرى وعلى ضوء العلاقات الروسيه
الصينيه المعقده حقيقه هناك استيعاب صيني
الاقتصاد الروسي هناك ايمنه كبيره وخاصه
في شرق روسيا وايضا توجهها لصين بالسيطره
على اسيا الوسطى وهذا عمليا يعني يضر
بمصالح روسيا ولكن ظروف التي تعيشها روسيا
من حصار وعقوبات غربيه بسبب اوكرانيا
تجعلها تبلع هذه المشاكل وتحاول ان تجامل
الصين لكن ضمنا
روسيا غير مرتاحه من هيمنه الصين على دول
اسيا
واضح دكتور لورينز وترميني ماذا عن
الرساله التي يمكن ان تفهمها قمه مجموعه
السبع وهي تنعقد بالتزامن مع هذه القمه
فيه هيروشيما وعنوانها يعني التوسع
الاقتصادي الصيني
الصين كانت
تحاول وضع خططها
من خلال مبادره معروفه باسم الطريق
والحزام
والغرض منها هو ان يكون لها منافذ وان
يكون لديها مساحات
للانتاج الفاظ عن الحاجه داخل الصين نفسها
ولكن المشكله هنا هو ان بلدان اسيا الوسطى
وبشكل متكرر تتعرض لمحاولات
تقويضي الامن فالصين تحاول ان تعزز
استثماراتها
بالبدء بباكستان ثم في بلدان اخرى هذه هي
الاولويه رقم واحد بالنسبه للصين لكن قبل
تكون هناك ايه خطط من حيث تدعيم البنى
التحتيه على الصين ان تتوصل الى اتفاقيات
مع هذه البلدان لتامين استثماراتها ولو
كان هذا على حساب تاكل النفوذ الروسي
الصين لا يهمها ذلك لان الصين عفوا روسيا
الان في موقع ضعيف ولا تتوقع تصير منها
ردات فعل قويه اذا اللحظه مناسبه للصين ان
تتوسع لان ان روسيا الان تواجه مشكلات في
موقفها الاقتصادي والجيوساسي لحظه مناسبه
كما يقول دكتور لورنزو ترميني ولكن ان
تحدثنا عن امتعاض ضمن روسي من هذا التوسع
الصيني ضمن مناطق النفوذ الروسيه هل يمكن
ان يؤثر على التقارب الروسي الصيني الحاصل
حاليا
لا لا اعتقد انه سيؤثر لان روسيا بحاجه
ماسه للصين ويعني نحي الاقتصاديه تعتمد
بشكل كبير جدا على الصين تصدر لها الغاز
وتستورد عن طريقها صناعات ومنتجات كثيره
غذائيه والى اخره وصناعيه وتكنولوجيا لكن
المنافسه قائمه يعني الصين لها استثمارات
هائله في هذه الوسطى يعني تزيد عشرات
المرات عن الاستثمارات الروسيه في اسيا
الوسطى الى جانب ان طبعا
الدول الاسيو الوسطى كلها لها موقف من كل
السياسه الخارجيه الروسيه في موضوع
اوكرانيا وغيرها يعني والصين كان الرئيس
الصيني من سنه تقريبا في كازاخستان اعلن
انه
يدعم وسياده ووحده اراضي كازاخستان يعني
هذا هذه كانت رساله موجهه لروسيا لا احد
يهدد يمكن ان يهدد اراضي كازاخستان الا
روسيا يعني عمليا
متخوفه كما قلت والصين هي الحامله لهم وهي
تدعمهم اقتصاديا وتبني لهم مشاريع وطبعا
تستورد الغاز والنفط من اسيا الوسطى
والذهب والمعادن وغيرها وبنفس الوقت هي
كما تحدث الضيف من ايطاليا
هي ايضا تنفذ مشروعها الاستراتيجي حزام
واحد وطريق واحد
والذي يمر عبر اسيا الوسطى يعني عمليا
هناك مصالح مشتركه بين روسيا والصين كبيره
جدا
وفي نفس الوقت هناك منافسه ولكنها مضطر
لتحمل الدور الصيني في اسيا الوسطى واضح
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور محمود الحمزه
الاكاديمي والبحث في شؤون روسيا واسيا
الوسطى من موسكو وشكرا للدكتور لورينزو
ترميني الباحث المختص في الشؤون الاسيويه
في مركز الدراسات الجيو السياسيه والجامعه
سفيانزا ضيفنا من روما بهذا مشاهدينا نصل
الى نهايه حصاد هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم
تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]